let's move on to the coaching carousel
matt eberflus a name that has come up
for
many of the vacant jobs he's the colts
defensive coordinator who will try to
slow down the buffalo offense in the
first game to be played on saturday
reportedly turns down an offer to
interview for the texans head coaching
job and
shireen when i saw that today after we
finished pft live and i was catching up
on some of the stories that were out
there and what we were writing and what
we were thinking about writing that to
me was significant because that meshes
with my perception on the situation if
you have options
you're not taking the texans job because
other options are going to be better
because right now the texans have
plunged into full-blown dysfunction with
jack easter be
somehow acquiring even more power
despite no credentials or qualifications
all due respect and this desean watson
situation
where
he's not happy with the team and there
are now multiple reports that confirm in
many different ways how he's not happy
with the team and it just feels like
it's a matter of time before he asks to
be traded and if i'm matt aboutflu
shireen i am not interested in that job
and if i'm anyone who has another
opportunity as a head coach for 2021 i'm
not interested and even if i don't have
another opportunity i'm thinking i'm
gonna wait till next year to seek out a
head coaching job
well and that's what i was gonna say
mike you go back to sean payton
interviewed with the raiders they
offered him the head coaching job way
back when and the cowboys talked him out
of it and they said that's not the place
for you to go you need to come back you
need to wait another year that's just
not a good situation to be in and he
went back to dallas offensive
coordinator the next year he gets a
saints job and the rest is history it's
got to be the right fit and i don't know
that who is the right fit for houston
they'll find somebody obviously there's
somebody out there who wants to be a
head coach but that's a tough situation
to go to and mike this might be the
worst run organization i i think it is
the worst run organization now in the
nfl but it might be the one of the worst
run organizations in all of sports i
don't know the other sports well enough
to say that definitively but i do think
they're poorly run right now
since their owner died and with cal
mcnair running things it's just not a
good place to be with everything that's
happened with the drop trading deandre
hopkins and on and on and on we know
everything that's gone on there but one
thing that was curious to me mike and
this also shows what a poorly run
organization they are they repeatedly
said we're going to hire the gm first
and he's going to have a say in hiring
the head coach but yet they started
interviewing head coaches before they
did that and i don't know who made the
call to matt everfloos or his agent to
ask about interviewing him but was that
done before they hired their gm or after
they hired their gm but either way it's
a messed up situation in houston
regardless of the timing there i want
nothing to do with it because of the
desean watson situation that continues
to move toward full boil and
i i think people who haven't studied the
situation carefully maybe just pick up
bits and pieces we'll hear that there's
a degree of discontent by desean watson
because he wasn't consulted before nick
casario was hired and because he
recommended that eric be enemy be hired
to be the coach and they didn't even
interview him the obvious reaction that
by the casual fan that isn't following
the story is to say
well it's not the quarterback's job to
be involved
the difference is
the texans made it clear to him
that he would be involved here's cal
mcnair from the press conference that
introduced nick casario earlier today as
the general manager talking about the
extent to which desean watson had input
in these key hires
i've come to understand that it's been
reported
that deshaun feels left out of the
process
that he and i had several visits and i
understood his point of view before
meeting with candidates
i've reached out to deshawn about nick's
hire
and i look forward to him getting back
to me when he returns from his vacation
wow
that that is that is called clumsily
putting lipstick on the uh on on the
nose of a pig because you missed the
mouth
that uh
this is what you get frankly when you
hire someone who's unqualified and
inexperienced to run your football
operation things like this happen you
implement plans that maybe you shouldn't
have you didn't want to or you didn't
want to follow because i think that what
they simply did here was create the
illusion of input for desean watson and
they're not listening to desean watson
this is the organization after all that
brought us we can't have the inmates
running the prison do you really think
they're going to listen to desean watson
do you really think they're going to do
what desean watson wants them to do
they believed i believe that they would
be able to kind of smooth it all over
and talk it all through well
that bridge has been crossed and the
question is has the rubicon been crossed
into sean watson's mind is there a way
to go back from this that's why if i'm
mad eberflus no thank you if i'm any
other candidate other than eric b enemy
who's not getting an interview my
position is no thank you unless you can
tell me a detailed plan for how you're
going to deal with this and there's two
ways to deal with it one
you find a way to get deshawn watson
happy again two
you find a way to move on from deshaun
watson and get a herschel walker type of
a trade package for him because unlike
herschel walker deshawn watson would
actually merit that type of return
shireen
well mike if i'm a serious candidate for
this job i want to talk to deshaun
watson if the texas want me i've got to
talk to sean watson before i take this
job because if you don't have a happy
quarterback
you're not going to have a very good
team because you look at the talent on
that team and there's not a whole lot
there that defense is in tatters it's
got to be totally rebuilt they don't
really have a running back after the
trade they got david johnson there's
still questions in the offensive line
there's questions that receivers will
will fuller is a free agent i mean
there's just so many questions on that
team this looks like a long rebuild to
me despite what desean watson did this
season and despite how good he is and i
don't know that people realize that
because their record's so bad you have
to have more than a quarterback a
quarterback can only take you so far if
the rest of the talent around you is
that bad
you're not going to win many games and
they didn't win many games and they've
got a long way to go to try to get back
to winning games and and winning the
division frankly so it's got to be a
coach that a has no other options or b
that that desean watson wants otherwise
you're going to have a coach who's going
to go in there and the quarterback's not
going to be happy and this is going to
be a really hard job
or c a coach who is confident in their
plan for trading deshaun watson even
though they say they're not going to
trade desean watson and before we hear
from nick casario on that point let me
just say i'm impressed by the manner in
which you powered through your answer
even though while fumbling through my
phone you may have heard the voice of
o.j simpson a video that was sent to me
regarding his observations about recent
events including his own disagreement
with the results of a verdict that was
against him in the civil justice system
so sorry about that but good job pushing
through it here's nick casario pushing
through the answer to the question of
where things stand with deshaun watson
i think each year is a new year ever
we're starting from scratch and i think
the most important thing for us is just
to speak specifically to desean i'd say
from far the respect and admiration that
that i have for him as a player and what
he's done for this organization is
significant he's our quarterback quite
frankly he's a big part of the reason
why over the last two seasons when we
faced uh we faced the texans that new
england came out in the uh the losing
side of the ledger so i think it's
important for all of us to take some
time and i think you know when the time
is appropriate we'll have discussions
with the players i think it's important
for us whatever conversations that we're
going to have with players about their
individual situation that we do it
directly um we do it face-to-face and
you know when the appropriate time comes
we'll sit and spend some time with
desean but certainly looking forward to
the opportunity to to work with him
you know it's so strange when you see
someone you've never seen in a suit
before in a suit for the first time
and i'm still scarred by the ben mcadoo
experience from several years ago when
he showed up in the giant suit the giant
david byrne stopped making sense suit
and uh it's it's always impressive when
you see
someone in a suit that actually fits so
well done nick casario but uh look this
deshaun watson thing needs to get solved
and this idea that i look forward to
desean watson calling me back when he
returns from his vacation did he
surrender his phone before he went on
vacation i mean i i look at it this way
i i i do go on vacation from time to
time it's typically a working vacation
but if the person that signs my checks
calls me while i'm on vacation
i take the call
or if for some reason i'm in the middle
of vacation activities and i get the
message
i call him back
so i i'm not buying this all as well
nothing to see here there is something
to see here there's a problem and i
don't think deshawn watson's the kind of
guy who plays around he's not trying
some leverage deal i think once you lose
him you've lost him there's no getting
him back that's just my hunch gut
feeling based on knowing him talking to
him being around him i don't know him
all that well but i don't think he's
going to be a guy who plays games you
know he's not going to be into the drama
like oh i don't know ben roethlisberger
would be he's going to say he wants out
or suggest he wants out or think he
wants out only if wait for it he wants
out
yeah i'm
right there with you mike i i do think
he might be at that point where there's
no turning back and the bur the bridge
has been burned down and
he maybe the best option for him is this
at this point is going elsewhere and if
he pushes that i mean the texas can say
all they want we're not trading you but
if deshawn watson wants out he can make
it where the texans have to trade him
because he is just as you said an
employee you show up only when you have
to show up you do the bare minimum and
eventually they're going to get rid of
you and we're seeing it in the nba in
the same city with james harden mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports